Elon Musk says something really
interesting and it's kind of touchy
subject so just bear with me the way I
tried to paraphrase this he basically
said that death is good the reason he
said that death is good is because it
allows new ideas to come that's what he
said okay I know it's a little harsh but
that's what he said so back to the
coffee shop example right now yeah it's
only Bitcoin Fanatics that accept
Bitcoin um at these coffee shops I agree
with you but as this new generation who
really understands digital technology
gen Z as we become older we approach our
30s our 40s our 50s we are going to be
doing business in Bitcoin and other
cryptocurrencies right now I actually
pay people on bitcoin